this video is sponsored by babyon better
help more on them after the reaction
people what up citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch the Grand
Theft auto6 official trailer I've been
at Carmax for like the last 6 hours this
came out right when I arrived at Carmax
but it allowed me the opportunity to
talk with some people on social media
because I only play Grand Theft Auto 3
Vice City and San Andreas so there's a
couple that I missed oh I played those
and I played four oh
congratulations but people said no we
should still check out the trailer cuz
it's been like a decade or a while
you're at the car dealership try to
legally anyway guys let's see what's
going on in this trailer and what all
the hype's about because people are
talking about it primarily because it's
been like a very very long time but
let's
see
who Lucia
Luc bad luck I guess woke Theft Auto
are we back in Florida are we back in uh
in Vice
yeah I think we are it looks like a swap
damn look at the beach the character
model sir yeah I mean that looks like
La holy moly I think we're going
everywhere it was definitely now this
looks like just
[Music]
Vice
ooh it is vice okay Tik tok's reals one
of those look a little San Andreas
but
Florida yeah Florida
man guys watering it is
underwear look who's back gr Theft
Auto's back
em whoa whoa dirt dir bike dirt
bags so the main characters a
couple
trust dang okay you what you choose
which one you want to
be the Vice that's pretty exciting is
exciting yeah no
definitely oh wow I need to pick it back
up man I got some thoughts let's hear
them all right after a word from our
sponsor hello there esteem viewer of the
real rejects hi Greg Alba language
connoisseur and world gentlemen I'm here
to bestow upon you the secrets of Babel
the language app that transforms mere
mortals into linguistic gods in just 3
weeks why Babel you inquire my dear
friends in this age of monolingual
mundanity mundanity mity mundanity Babel
is our Beacon of Hope crafted by an army
of over 150 language experts their
lessons are like linguistic caviar Rich
refined and oh so satisfying personal
tale of Triumph I once whispered sweet
nothings in Spanish or for the lame in
espanol to my wife courtesy of Babel her
reaction was well I'll tell you she was
utterly Bewitched Greg you silver tongue
devil no paraphrasing she exclaimed such
vocabulary as I bass in the glory of my
perfect pronunciation as Babel isn't
just about learning words it's about
embracing the art of conversation with
podcasts live classes and a veritable
smorgus sport of interactive
lessons I know the words I'm saying and
their speech recognition it's like
having a personal language Butler
ensuring every syllable is impeccably
Cris that breaks yourselves for an offer
of monumental proportions here's a
special limited time deal for our
viewers and listeners to get you started
right now get 55% off your Babel
subscription but again only for our
viewers at babel.com
rejects 55% off at babel.com
rejects spelled b a BB
l.com rejects rules and restrictions May
apply join me the Greg Alin the
adventure of language Mastery at Babel
we shall not just learn no nay we shall
conquer the world of communication or as
they say in
Spanish
we're done with this ad all righty time
to get a little bit serious so around
the holiday season we often focus on
getting gifts for others but it's also
important to consider the gifts that we
give to ourselves personally I found
that maintaining mental health balance
is a continuous Journey cuz like I've
mentioned before I've been diagnosed
with type 2 bipolar ADHD and PTSD and in
a lot of ways I've also grown up in the
last few years on camera with you guys
and therapy has been a crucial part of
my life before the channel even and like
many of you my anxiety and depression
seems to magnify this time of year still
don't quite understand the winter Blues
but it does however does help me
navigate the ups and downs and stay
grounded for the most part and while I
have my own approach to therapy I
understand everyone's path is unique and
that's why we are proud to be sponsored
by betterhelp this week it's an online
platform that makes therapy accessible
and tailored to your needs and I know a
few people who have discovered therapy
via betterhelp and it has been
transformative you start with a
questionnaire that helps match you with
a licensed therapist and the best part
and an important part you can switch
therapist anytime ensuring the right fit
for you better help is all about
convenience and flexibility it fits into
your schedule and it's all online so
whether you're looking to start therapy
for the first time or continue your
journey better help can be a great
option so in the season of giving
remember to give yourself what you need
too with better help take that step
towards your better self so you can
visit betterhelp.com rejects for 10% off
your first month that's better
hp.com rejects take care and stay
healthy reject Nation happy holidays
we're starting off we seeing this Lucia
girl and I feel like this would probably
be the start of the game right like it
starts off where she is uh you're being
pared being paroled but then she's
immediately going to go back to the life
she knows Life Of Crime with her hot
boyfriend and I could see my immediately
that ending shot made me go uh I could
see myself getting invested into it like
a modern day Bonnie and Clyde sort of a
situation totally these thieves well
gangsters criminals but you know I I
naturally just going to be very drawn
and connected to oh there are a couple
and I can get Bard with it one of them
has to die they do but before that
happens there's got to be like a
couple's mode you can play in where like
you and your partner you know can choose
one of the players and then like you
know ruin your own relationship through
the game you your own bad decision
making of the game but what's cool about
this is it's all like cinematic Graphics
but it's Grand Theft Auto so you know
that you're going to be able to partake
in a lot of what we're seeing on screen
like debauchery in the debauchery like
you're looking at the speedboats you're
looking at Yachts that people on the
beach you imagine you're going to be
able to go into I want to see that beach
shot again because the city looks so
huge oh yeah this is this is massive
yeah and so much of the charm of all
these games is just how open the open
world is and just getting to explore and
and yeah cause havoc in every kind of
environment want a mud booat it's going
to be fun to this like fan boat it's
going to be fun to ride around on that
thing oh yeah that's what I love about
this because it's all cinematics but you
know you're going to be able to actually
use everything that you're seeing here
on screen your crime Stars up stealing
someone fan po but this the amount of
this is going to sound strange but I
think Grand Theft Auto players will know
what I'm talking about the amount of
bodies that are
yes absolutely cuz you get a mess with
all of them you can interact with them
all you might even be able to form
meaningful relationships with someone
that's what we're all Hing for but like
the amount of bodies there are the
amount of different types of bodies that
there are as well it feels like you're
on an actual beach somewhere it the the
model designs here are insane look at
this dude this muscled out guy I know I
know and then this other guy with like a
bandana on his head just drifting into
the water elar oh my God this that these
couple shots made me feel like oh maybe
we're back in San Andreas but n this is
this is all it's just a City night life
with the crazy cool gangster day life
that we know that's right that that we
spend most of our waking hours in places
like this we got out of prison we said
we're going to start a YouTube channel
my God is that where I spend every wake
like every Saturday afternoon you know
just like chilling with my boys I
imagine that with these two guys who we
just saw here anyone that were getting
like close-ups on I
imagine characters yeah or people are
going to send you on pretty notable
missions yeah or rival gangs oo there's
got to be I hope we get to encounter
Dexter Morgan here
yes TV showtime cross is this the first
one to go back to Vice comment in
comment down below look at that water
yeah oh my god well that's the thing too
is like there's there's honey there's
always oh my God yes please this has to
be the most screenshotted moment of the
entire trailer yeah don't put any of the
notable characters just this girl posing
at this trailer have a Michael Bay movie
right here yeah well that's the thing is
like there's always like this sort of
like a c no matter how good the graphics
get and I don't mean this as a slight
there's always like something a little
bit Whimsical about the animation of a
Grand Theft Auto game and so to see
these people looking so photo and to see
so many like you know bikini beach babes
and stuff like that and and like you
know tanning oil dudes it's it's fun and
fascinating because again this is like
as beautiful and photoreal as this has
ever looked and yet it still hasn't lost
that unique kind of cheeky Grand Theft
Auto cartoon quality I completely agree
with every sentiment you have here John
and this right here has got to be a
Leonard DiCaprio over Jack Nicholson
Wolves of Wall Street baby right here
hanging out with everyone oh this is
that same girl who we just saw closeup
on I'm going to commit her to memory if
you squint long enough you can see past
the animation stuff maybe the animation
thing is the thing you guys are into too
yeah totally hey there's going to be a
lot of messing with alligators in this
yes I want to kill I want to rack up a
body count only based on alligators
alone I love twerking on the top you got
to get it Ghost Ride the Whip it's like
the it's like what Lizzie McGuire looks
like
now let let her live at the gas station
don't be out here creeping with your
phone it's I love how they're like
playing on uh Tik toks and reals Yeah
well yeah cuz like you're causing the
kind of people would yeah you're causing
the kind of havoc and also living the
kind of you know glit see wildlife that
I guess a lot of people on Tik Tok and
the like would want to live or at least
showcase themselves living I love this
yes yeah and I'm like is this
reminisence of a real shot we'll see in
the game based on some action you had
control over or is this like a random
moment for the trailer body cams okay
these are cops going in here yeah oh my
god do you get to play as cops ever you
get to play I think I don't know there's
a couple of games I have totally missed
so I'm not sure but yeah I feel like
five would be a good Touchstone to go
back for in terms of what modern modern
GTA has become look at that look at that
com yeah see I love that this trailer
lot of details in this trailer when you
slowing down yeah no it's beautiful and
like what's great is this trailer pulls
you in with the stuff you remember from
Vice City of like oh yeah we're at the
beach and it's glamorous and it's Miami
life and then we slowly descend into
like Florida man chaos by the end of the
trailer which I'm sure was always there
but yeah like it takes a marked turn
here look at these Biden supporters
that's right man keep America Joe keep
America
Brandon oh she's got to be hat she's got
to be a returning character look who's
back that's right that's the line that
she has it cures emotions oh my God what
is that a play on John Ang
Stan America's favorite F does it say it
back America's
favorite
disassociative is that
medication Yeah well yeah I mean it's
definely play on vid yeah no but yeah I
think it's some kind of like was a play
on The Rona but it looks like it's a
plan like an anti-anxiety measure yeah
it's like a pH I think it says America's
favorite dissoc dissociative so yeah
it's like it must help you just Divorce
Yourself from all
reality oh no overturn weasel news uh oh
and jaral letto
Joker imp meets the guy the
yeah definitely Suicide Squad maybe
that's what we needed maybe he's like
the main one of the main villains I
don't know could be I got the imagery
like and the way they're so good at like
recreating news footage and stuff like
that in these games dirt bike dirt B
dirt bags weasel news they're just
misunderstood oh yeah this is a cool
couple to look at man yeah this is so
cool looking I got to say and it has
that like Natural Born Killers like even
though you're not really Natural Born
Killer is more rap than Bonnie and Clyde
sure and you're spending a whole lot of
time on like the main characters they
don't look like murderers they look like
robers like they're like maybe they
don't want to kill they just have to
kill they look like people who were only
doing this until they could get out you
know yeah for sure yeah misunderstood
that's the Hope anyway you know because
people are always playing these games
with an eye for the morality I imagine
they have a kid or some she's got
to have a bigger cause than just getting
back in right I feel like that'll
probably be it yeah no they're going to
take us on a harrowing emotional Journey
probably get you emotionally involved by
going oh she's got a kid yeah and she's
doing crimes we got to protect our belly
and someone coms like why does she have
to have a kid cuz she's a woman yes
that's why yeah yes that's why they're
like putting a woman the lead of our
game we're required to have her a baby
got to have a woman we got to have a
woman baby a woman baby woman with a
baby woman with a baby all righty guys
what you think about the Grand Theft TR
live to the hype leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave a
like and um I I I am in the process of
over the next year trying to figure out
how to do live stream Let's Plays but oh
I don't know I've never done it before
so I have to figure it out but I will
leave it to me go ahead John do it see
you
[Music]
guys